vous avez conscience d'être très belle
je suis pas dit non la gueule que j'ai
on écoute et vous exagérez ah oui les
défis que vous êtes merveilleusement
bien photographier oui ah bon bah c'est
le chef opérateur monsieur c'est pas moi
même vous arrive pas de vous mettre
devant une glace puis de vous dire non
je ne sais plus à ça m'emmerde je ne
vais plus me regarde n'est pas un peu
l'impression d'être de mauvaise foi et
de mauvaise foi non comment ne pas
reconnaître vous êtes une femme très
belle mais non d'un coup je suis
photogénique mon père est toujours dit
je suis photogénique c'est tout tu as de
la chance qui est photogénique c'est
tout vous avez parfois songer à annoncer
votre carrière
vous n'y songez jamais si ça arrivera
qu'est ce qui pourra faire arrêter votre
carrière
moi même
c'est tout
j'aime pas pensé à ça
ce qui vous arrive de la même façon de
songer à la vieillesse
la vieillesse ça me fait pas peur